خذلان وتخلان وغضب مشاعر تختلط بالبرد
والفقد والدموع السوريون حملوا مجددا
اكياس الجثث التي اعتادوا حملها لسنوات
بعضهم حظي باقامه طقوس وداعا وان كانت
مختصره والبعض الاخر لا يزال بمرحله
انتظار خروجهم من تحت الانقاض
الحرقه لم تزل ببدايتها لكن الغضب عارم لم
يعتادوا البقاء في الصف الخلفي رغم اهمال
اوضاعهم لسنوات فصرخاتهم ليست لغطاء او
طعام رغم ضاله المساعدات التي وصلت الى
الشمال غرب سوريا وانعدامها ببعض المناطق
ما اريد اكل نريد ناكل التراب بس انحفظ
كرامتنا السوريون يصفونه بالتخلي
والنسيانه مع التماسهم لفروق كثيره في
التعامل المحلي والدولي مع جيرانهم
الاتراك شركائهم بالكارثه والدمار الكارثه
لم تقدر حدودا لكن الجدار بينهما حدد وحدد
خدمات كثيره من الانقاذ للاسعاف للماوى
فعلى الجهه الاخرى من الجدار الاف عمال
الانقاذ والالاف من المسعفين اضافه الى
معدات رفع ثقيله وجرافات وكلاب بوليسيه
تجب الشوارع صخب محركات ضغط عليه احيانا
صافره سيارات الاسعاف وزحام المساعدات لكن
في الجهه السوريه وقفت عمليات الانقاذ منذ
يومين صمت مستغرب تحتمه امكانات محدوده مع
تفوق الكارثه على قدرات الخوض البيضاء
نقاط التفتيش احبطت جهود الاغاثه الدوليه
والمساعده العاجله في الجزء الذي تسيطر
عليه الفصائل المدعومه من تركيا
والمساعدات المنتظره تعرقل دخولها لاكثر
من منطقه بسبب تقسيمات جغرافيه وانقسامات
سياسيه وولائيه